rivals banding together to fight a
common foe happens all the time just
think about it Game of Thrones house of
cards that enemy mind movie was Dennis
Quaid and Lou Gossett jr. it's happening
again
this time between Samsung and Google
with the unveiling of Samsung's latest
flagship the galaxy s5 it heralds a new
era of good feelings between the two
frenemies last month the two companies
announced a sweeping agreement regarding
patents and intellectual property that
will increase cooperation between
Samsung and Google moreover it's
expected that Samsung will tone down
development of its own apps favoring
ones made by Google previous Galaxy S
users were faced with this weirdo Mirror
Universe with Google and Samsung apps
that basically did exactly the same
thing that should and soon with Google
Apps coming out on for Samsung letting
Google zaps any more of the spotlight
may be the most expedient move it's
pretty clear that Google wants a tighter
rein on its Android operating system
because the OS is open source any
company can use it and any company can
modify it as it chooses including
cutting Google entirely out of the
picture for example Amazon's Kindle
products run on Android but all apps and
services go back to Amazon not to Google
and Samsung can sleep easier at night
knowing that Google has sold Motorola a
hardware rival that was always making
things a little bit awkward between the
two companies and it's not like there
aren't other rivals out there amazon's
one face books another and of course
there's always Apple for Samsung and
Google things right now are a little bit
like that episode the day of the dove in
Star Trek where Kirk forms the alliance
with the Klingons you know